[Music]
hi I'm Dan Hines and I'm here with Randy
Pitchford and we are playing Borderlands
the Pre-Sequel now Randy what is this
that we are actually playing here
something new we're not merely playing
Borderlands the Pre-Sequel you're
playing as Handsome Jack we're playing
as Handsome Jack you're playing as
Handsome Jack so the first DLC package
that's going to come out for Borderlands
the Pre-Sequel is this new character
which is uh you play as Handsome Jack
for the very first time and this will
come out actually November 11th so
you're getting a a sneak peek I'm pretty
much wrapped everything up but we're you
know we're coming in for for landing
with this guy and let me introduce you
to him why don't we in fact do you mind
if I take the mouse and keyboard and
I'll introduce you to the skill tree and
then you can uh you can play so first
we're going to take a look
at um let's let's use the skill browser
here so this is Handsome Jack of course
and um this is Jack before he's known as
Handsome Jack right well it's yeah it
takes place during the the Pre-Sequel
which takes place before Borderlands 2
but after Borderlands won so it's before
he
becomes um the CEO of Hyperion
Corporation but in fact he has those
Ambitions and Jack is you know he's the
main I guess NPC protagonist of the
Pre-Sequel so he's an NPC in the game
but you're playing as him you might not
exactly be playing as him what what Jack
has done is he's made a body double and
when I say he's made a body double I
mean he's taken a human being and he has
surgically altered that person changed
their changed their appearance uh
trained them to you know mimic the same
mannerism has he pinned his face on them
he's got a thing for pinning faces on
right this is before he has his mask so
that hasn't that hasn't happened yet the
mask the scar that that was caused by
the Vault hasn't burned him yet um so
and and his class here is called the
doppelganger so this is now one of the
interesting things though if if you
wanted to create say a body double for
yourself and you made it really obvious
that's the body double and I'm the real
person um it's kind of pointless right
it's right so unless you're
lying unless you're lying right so which
one's the real Jack so are you saying
that we could go through this game and
the NPC that we've been talking to the
Jack NPC might not actually be the real
Jack could be we've we're we're leaving
that ambiguous it's up to you to decide
which Jack is the real Jack okay I like
to think that this playable Jack this is
the real Jack so but it's up to you
whatever whatever you think is cool now
Jack has skills like any other hero in
the game so now that you're playing as
Jack you'll have an action skill his is
called Expendable assets and this allows
him to spawn digistruct copies of
themselves that we call Digi jaacks and
so a couple of these guys will appear
they actually will attract the attention
of the enemy they can shoot they can
actually cause damage to the enemy they
can get kills they're pretty rad um it's
a really power powerful special ability
and some of the skill trees will
actually um affect that um increase the
capabilities of your dig jaacks so when
they spawn do they have the same weapon
as you um depends depends um most of the
time they use the wrist Rockets but
depends on how you have the skill set up
uh for example there's a skill let me
show you over here in the hero of the
story skill tree um here's a skill
called you have my shield that allows
the digi jaacks to get the same Shield
that you're using so there's things like
that throughout the skill trees now this
this particular skill tree here called
the hero of the SK the story is really
tanky kind of uh skill you'll notice
there's a lot of things that improve
your Shields capabilities improve health
um this one uh allows you to um shoot
faster and um have more benefits to your
digit jaacks if you um have higher
health so they they kind of go in line
together this increases your health and
the health of the uh the Dig Jacks and
so on uh the Capstone on this guy um is
is pretty rad basically it turns your
dig jaacks into badasses okay so and you
know what badasses are play and there's
also a couple things to help grenade uh
so if you like to play with grenades
this is a good skill tree to use uh this
is probably my favorite skill in the
entire game it doesn't actually do
anything it just allows him to monologue
at you so when you when you get
appropriate yes so Jack you know if you
like if you think Jack's funny or you
just enjoy how much of an [__] he is
um this is this is the skill for you cuz
you're definitely going to hear him rant
a bit when you when you use that skill
uh this middle skill tree the greater
good is a lot of fun this one uh I think
this one's actually good if you're a
noob or if you're like really really
Advanced but it's I mean it's there two
opposite things total and and here
here's why these two the Capstone and
the one before it uh potential really
work together now of course the main
thing that's described here under
potential is that when you spawn the
digi jaacks they create a shock NOA but
the real real magic to this one is that
you can now use your action skill when
you're in Fight to your fight for your
life so when you're down when you're in
your down state you can actually trigger
your action skill and when you combine
that with your Capstone leadership
whenever a digit Jack dies remember
digit Jacks respond when you use that
that action skill so whenever they die
it's as if you killed an enemy which
means all the things that happen when
you kill an enemy are triggered
including getting a second win so you
can basically spawn copies of yourself
sacrifice them to get yourself back
that's correct it's almost like a get
out of jail free card now you the thing
you'll notice on the skill tree is there
are three kill skills MH right like
we've never done that before so if if
you have that Capstone and killing your
you know when your digit Stu dies it's
as if you killed something that means
all of your kill skills will proc and
two of them increase damage that one
increases crit and weapon damage this
one increases things like accuracy and
you know reload and so on um and this is
more defensive but it also increases
movement speed so these things will be
constantly proing if you're using your
your um your actual skill a lot lot of
fun uh originally this great or good um
skill tree was going to be our Co-op
kind of skill tree and there's still a
remnant of that this is the
accountability skill um you know instead
of reading all the texts I'll just let
you know that if if anybody gets hit
that isn't you you get a buff and and
you get Stacks this buff so you want to
just hang back and like go ahead guys
you go jump in the fight and you know
let let your Co-op buddies take all the
hits it also works if your digu uh Digi
Jacks take damage so it sounds like
you've had a lot of fun bringing the
Thematic concept back into the actual
mechanics oh yeah in fact speaking of
that like this other Scale tree free
enterprise this is another one of my
favorite skills just pick up money and
get a buff like you just click because
there's cash everywhere in boxes and
toilets like what I don't know why
there's cash in toilets in Borderlands
but it just you know that's that's what
happens with the random loot system so
now this is the first time we've put a
mechanic on that so whenever you collect
cash as Jack um you get a buff you can
stack it up to 999 times and you don't
lose your Stacks unless you die or
unless you spend spend your money so
don't buy anything in the store just
hoard it don't spend it and you're good
to go uh this is a really fun skill Tre
too also I think this one's really good
for advanced players you'll notice some
um kind of wacky stuff this this skill
increases your weapon swap speed weapon
swapping is really important with this
particular tree um for example if you
swap weapons when you have incentives
your fire rate will increase but it gets
even wackier when you look at um things
like company man where depending on the
gear you have if you have Hyperion gear
you get more Buffs um so imagine you
have but but imagine the Hyperion gun
isn't your best one or most suitable so
you have it in your inventory swap to it
get your buff and then swap back out um
and then uh this is even crazier this is
the Capstone sponsored by the buff that
you get is affected by the weapon you
equipped last so you will have different
you know manufacturers in your skill
tree Hyperion will give you more
accuracy Jacobs gives you more damage
and so on and so on I like this it seems
like you're always trying to find ways
to put more emphasis on the different
manufacturers and ways to make you pay
attention he runs Hyperion Corporation
so he really cares about that and you
know this is this is kind of we were
playing with like his kind of free
enterprise capitalistic kind of you know
mentality and uh and we we found ways to
to basically add skill to that and add
gameplay to it there's also this really
cool skill if you've um if you've played
the game and you remember him as an NPC
he had these like things on his wrists
that allow him to like shoot enemies
with it well if you build out the free
enterprise skill tree that skill here
called merger uh lets you replace your
your melee attack with using those
weapons so you can actually and if you
get that your digit struct will use them
too so that's pretty cool um so if you
like why don't we chill for a minute
while you go through here and I'll let
you build out build this guy out however
you
want I'm really liking the sound of the
free enterprise tree it's a pretty good
tree all
right yeah and if you if you put in the
minimum set you'll definitely be able to
get to your Capone and have five or six
points left over so that you can uh cuz
we we're starting off at level 30 here
don't overdo those though you won't you
won't be able to we get that one down
there yeah so and you can put more into
um this one well you definitely take
take the Mele repl we got to see watch
his wrist when you take it watch his
wrist there you go look at that adds on
so like he actually gets the
augmentation um yeah company man's good
I'm not sure if we pre-loaded you with
some hyperian hyperian
stuff oh this is really cool too the
middle one there that's laser Surplus um
it's kind of like inspired by the how
The BFG worked in Doom 2 so it it kills
everything in the Viewpoint kind of yeah
yeah in the Viewpoint so like if you
fire the ball out it's not where the
ball explodes when the ball explodes it
actually creates these invisible rays
that come out from the play that's the
logic is a bit odd there so like imagine
you fired The BFG ball down one H
hallway R before hit you ran down and
are looking down a completely different
hallway Now The BFG hits there if
there's if there's monsters in front of
you in the hallway they'll just melt in
front of you so this triggers in on a
butt slam so when you have a butt slam
the the cone of lasers come out but it's
actually they're actually visible now so
you can just butt jump in front of a
group of guys and just melt a bunch of
guys in front of you I don't think
Borderland has ever been too concerned
with logic so fine we're it's it's fine
don't don't don't ask too many questions
just go with it it's cool everything's
fine all right there we go sponsored by
yeah so now you can and if you want your
five skill points left so you can you
can try some other things or you can
fill out the free enterprise some more
you won't be able to get beyond the
first tier but um you want to buff the
digi Jacks a little bit yeah that's cool
yeah cool yeah cool all right you're
ready to roll and I believe um Carl is
in this
game Carl
into so he's also going to play as Jack
so we're going to have twin Jacks which
means when each of you simultaneously
create your digu
uh your dig Jacks you're going to have
six Jacks running around the map are
they going to resemble our customized
appearance as well or um yeah yeah so
you in fact if you want to check out I
don't know if I should go ahead go ahead
go uh where's the um somewhere in
Concordia you know so there's Digi
jaacks so go go up to the uh to the
chain station there let's check out the
turn left use that use that vendor right
there you want to see some of the custom
heads and skins cuz Jack's also got
there's a couple of them we've got onl
here so that one's like Bane and there's
with a
crown I think Crown there's lots that
you can unlock too so I'm kind of
breaking the rules I think I promised
the pr folks we weren't going to show
any of this stuff but you know what for
you guys I okay look I got to go with
the pun so you know nice cyan believe it
is it cyan or Cayenne uh cyan yeah so
it's a spelling pun so how do you think
Jack plays in a group of uh the kind of
existing Vault Hunters as well like what
what what sort of role does he fill and
and what kind of play styles are you
seeing people if you really want to play
with your teammates I think the left
skill tree is is best it really turns
them into very good tank class and
attract a lot of the attention and
really crowd control while while your
teammates grind everybody down but um
you know one of the things about Jack he
he's got the especially the middle skill
tree and the skill tree on the right
they're they're really for advanced
players so so when you really get good
at them you're going to be doing
throughput that you just can't do with
the other characters but you have to
especially with free enterprise you have
to get really good at weapon switching
and and knowing what your load out is so
you're doing that um and and I think
he's going to be preferred for guys that
like to solo the hard stuff um the
middle skill tree is a lot of uh I think
it's really useful if like you want have
a friend that you want to invite to play
the game and you're playing split screen
because it's got so much survivability
with that Capstone you know just level
up a character for him and then let him
use one of your characters that's that
that you know he any time he goes down
and just I'll just hit your hit your
action skill and you'll be all right um
and that that's that's kind of nice for
new players that it might be dying a lot
when they're playing with I just swapped
in a new weapon cuz I notic we had two
Jacob's guns and so we want to get like
yeah one of each uh so that so now and
you can see the Buffs happening down
here as you switch weapons like see you
just got a stack got another stack so I
can just sit here and roll the mouse
wheel yeah and so now you got four
Stacks it also shows you which your so
now it's Hyperion so now that's Tor um
and each each one gives a different buff
so when you have the Jacobs weapons up
weapon up for example um next time you
cycle now you have Jacobs next time you
cycle Jacobs is your buff so that means
you have 30% plus 30% weap previous weon
previous weapon right so so this is a
Hyperion weapon so if you switch you're
going to get 30% accuracy so now it says
Hyperion you're going to have 30%
accuracy and anytime you're curious what
that table is you can go back to your
skill tree and look that up all right
let's take him for spin why should we
get um why don't we follow uh take us
somewhere let's kill some stuff man come
on call it's it's hard to like going
back and playing Borderlands 2 sucks now
because I want I want to double jump and
butt stomp stuff and I I hate not having
that capability does Jack have any
skills specific to like the low grow or
the laser weapons or the Cryer weapons
um there are some capabilities you can
add to digit structs that help you help
them have some Elemental effects like
cryo and Laser um he does have lots of
laser effects for example you did equip
the butt stomp one so if you if you go
and butt stomp on a guy um you'll you'll
have the the cone of of beams laser
beams fly out from your body and kill
dudes are you sure you're a mouse and
keyboard player hey hey hey hey I got to
get back in the groove okay it's all
good I'm
just all right can't play a game like
this that a little Trash Talk don't
forget you can double jump yeah you got
it and you must be great you're hanging
out with
[Music]
me so he he chose that other uh that
other skill tree yeah so now everybody's
inspired there's a bouncy on that
guy I notice there's kind of a running
theme with Jack and uh clap trap as well
that sort of gets up in other people's
grills and kind of not just ruins their
game but sort of throws them off for a
second oh man the clap trap character is
just like I don't if you've ever played
a game with four Cloud traps like it's
just insane because you don't know
what's going to happen when you uses
action
skill so uh and but I'll tell you
sometimes they throw people off but if
you get players that really know the
game well and know what each of the
action skills not do um it you can get
really effective by taking advantage of
whatever happens to randomly happen with
clap trap for example a lot of people
don't like the bounce one CU you're like
kind of out of control bouncing
everywhere but basically it's free
infinite butt Stomps yeah right so and
your butt stop immediately launches you
back up in the air again for another
butt Stomp
so um Jack's got a little bit of that
kind of stuff um if you get multiple
Jacks in a game like just having some
destruct Jacks
out there you go
just so no they're going to go after dig
jaacks and notice how your dig Jacks
have the arm AR weapons cuz you equip
that skill so what's cool about them is
when they die the new one will spawn
right away like as long as it's active
you can also hold down your action skill
button again and and and release it
you'll get some of your cool down back
oh great so now your cool Down's already
ready again let's go and use some of my
uh melee oh yeah that's cool waa and
that cool that is awesome that is a lot
that's a lot more range than I was
expecting yes yes it's no longer a melee
weapon but like the most badass laser
ever yeah so that cool down is that
middle icon there for that um yeah yeah
so you're going to in M until it's back
so you can see your Buffs so they on the
bar above your experience bar this will
be good
now the stack of 17 that I have there
that's the um that's your cash the cash
so you've gotten 17 Stacks from
collecting cash if you buy anything or
die you'll lose those stacks and each
stack gives you a little bit of a buff
so you're going to be that guy in the
party that's like hey man could you buy
this for me and yeah exactly yeah
actually I don't know if it resets if
you trade so you could trade somebody
give them your cash and have them buy
the item for you that's funny I that
might be a loophole I will have to patch
that
he just made me think of something
exploits speaking of exploits I mean
like I saw uh the video of one of the
characters taking down the secret boss
in a single hit with a certain sort of
variety of yeah that guy the crap out of
the game do you see that an as an
exploit or is something like what
whatever you you can find me on record
even before we Shi Borderlands one
saying like when you make a game like
this where you have procedurally
generated weapons and you have like a
really insane combination of skills uh
that those kinds of edge cases are going
to exist like there's all kinds of weird
edge cases that happen just from what
can be generated by the weapon system um
we just said ah so what if you find a g
a gamebreaking gun good for you like you
just you win you have the I win button
now go ahead and have fun killing
everybody and uh you know there there's
some people that um if gearbox that kind
of disagree with that but so far
we've only really patched things when
functionality has been wrong so like
when we patched the the B Shield it was
because it was actually not working the
way it was supposed to not because we
were trying to Nerf something um there
are plenty of almost
game-breaking uh things that you can
find in Borderlands and all power to it
kind of it's part of the fun of farming
you know it's possibility finding that
weird stuff never limit yourself there
you go is power
Inspire oh shoot that guy just
B like your Jacks are just killing them
that's good because you seem to miss
knobs messing with you it's very helpful
yeah I think I'll go don't foret you can
you can do your butt stop thing um also
your lasers are
up I teleporting along with you they'll
they'll respawn when they get out of
range of you when they die they'll
respawn I really I don't know I love
those space helmets on these guys that
did justu oxygen
bubbles like it was actually one of the
guys on the 2K o team that came up with
that and I was you're a damn
genius did you see that
you've got laser shotgun
dude look at that thing that's
cool oh that Tor weapon is really
sick and your accuracy is really
improved right now so it's cuz it's cuz
it's you know a wi well it's a Hyperion
thing too you got you got better
accuracy so it's actually narrowing the
spread even more and uh and
it's
what is Jack's opinion of
Australians um I don't know man I mean
well first of all actual Australians
don't exist in Jack's world right there
are Earth doesn't even exist in this
universe but as far as like the
inhabitants of the Moon you know times
he kind of uses them and needs them to
help what what he's trying to accomplish
so I guess the kind of
allies but I mean he's so narcissistic
and um sociopathic that once you become
come a problem or not align with his
goals it doesn't matter where you're
from or who you
are yeah I thought you know given that a
huge percentage of our customer base is
really narcissistic and sociopathic it
was time to finally give them a player
character that can identify with did you
did you well you made a game about
collecting loot for yourself so not
doesn't really surprise not merely
collecting loot but killing people and
taking their loot like you had to we had
to build a universe where you were a
hero for killing people and taking their
[__] like that's that's where we
started and it's kind of funny how
like Hunter yeah it's kind of funny how
after you play the Pre-Sequel you're not
even sure who the good guys are anymore
that's because there aren't R any real
good
yes after the pre God I don't think I
like Lilith
anymore it's like yeah she just really
enjoyed incinerating people like she's
not exactly the greatest person person
she's she's super cool I like
it and we're back marvous you got a a
challenge
for for starving yourself of oxygen for
so long it's something I you know like
to do on
weekends you're creepy Mis hey Saturday
nights man whatever gets you there I'm
not juding how else do you think the
money ends up in the toilet oh
god oh oh you want do you want a job
writing for this game cuz I think you
that's just right in line
yeah oh
man I'm going to call Anthony sorry dude
you got
competition there are actually three
writers on the Pre-Sequel Anthony wrote
a bunch of the stuff for the characters
that we had in the games in the past and
uh there's an Aussie writer that did all
the Australian characters you got to
have them authentic right yeah yeah I
I'm not Australian so I don't know but
I've had since I've been over here I've
had people go you know usually when
Americans do Australian characters are
always freaking stupid but like you guys
are nailing it there's actually a gun um
yeah you guys have something called a
what is it a
Bogan yes yeah we do have that so
there's a there's a there's a Bogan gun
that just oh buella yeah no there's a
gun a weapon that talks and it and it
just cusses at you and it's just he's
just a complete dick it's hilarious that
is
actually this is so good like I when I
got it for the first time I I it was
really it's really been neat working on
this game too because because a lot of
the efforts Happening Here in Australia
with the 2K Australia team it's like I
get to play a lot of the content kind of
like with customer eyes you know where
the first time I'm seeing something
isn't because you know part of you know
Design Group or whatever but because
someone made it and they're just I'm
looking at it and when I first got the
Bogan Gun Man I just lost my [__] that
was the funniest thing I don't even have
that as part of our culture like I've
never heard of a Bogan before you're
just going to have to take that word for
it it's like no that's a thing don't
worry I I yeah I guess
so so when it came to making Jack as his
DLC character like obviously gearboxes
is the one that knows him the most right
yeah we actually did almost all of the
work on Jack um at gearbox so you know
it it's been a really interesting
collaborative effort when we first
started the
Pre-Sequel um we had just had a handful
of folks on that were really the you
know the franchise director and Anthony
and you know just really like highlevel
creative kind of overview um but then uh
in all of the main actual development
work was was 2K Australia and um in fact
as the game kind of went on we really
were liking where it was going a lot of
our guys just wanted to add stuff and
jump involved so by the time we got to
Beta I think like there were like twice
as many people in gearbox working on the
game as we're at 2K Australia so it was
really fun that we got a chance to get
in there and uh not because they needed
our help but just because we wanted to
do stuff and make the game and the game
was getting really good too so we wanted
to make it bigger and some of our guys
had some fun ideas for what they wanted
to do with them landscape and the moon
you know cuz we had never worked in this
environment before um so you know a lot
of our creatives just wanted to jump in
and do it but um now that we've shipped
the game and we're working on DLC the 2K
team is I love this part that effect is
so cool um the lava Bridge
freezes little [__] some fluid
dynamics courtesy of
Nvidia it's actually simulated on the
graphics
card what kind of liquid even is that I
don't know it's some weird cryo stuff
that's evaporating as it's flowing it's
weird
stuff um it's space liquid man come on
space liquid space juice it makes lava
cold
instantly but uh what was I talking
about oh yeah so on the DLC um so the 2K
Australia guys are just Neck Deep all in
on this campaign DLC that's going to
come a little later yeah and so we've
been working on like we worked on Jack
and we've been working on another
character and uh and we've been helping
with there's another there's four DLC
packages that are part of this the
season path so we've been helping with
three of the four
um and 2K Australia is just all in on
the campaign and I I can't talk about it
yet cuz it's like we're still yeah but
dude the concept is so [__] genius I
can't wait to talk about it oh man and
those guys I I don't even know what to
expect because we're not like directing
at ourselves the 2K Storia guys are
going for it the concept just blew my
blew me away though I heard like
probably I think I heard four pitches
from 2K Australia and probably six from
gear Bo people and this one it was a 2kr
pitch it's just so obviously so far and
above anything I'd ever heard before the
DLCs have always been really really
strongly because we don't care right
like you don't have to we don't have to
follow the same rules we don't have to
be commercial we can just say screw it
let's do weird crap that no one would
ever do in a game I think the Tony Tina
D and D one is still the the peak of
that that that is the high Watermark to
be honest though we kind of cheated we
spent way more like we we put like a
full game Budget on that oh really yeah
like it there's no like it'll never be
profitable that that particular DLC but
we didn't care because everything else
is so good and you know we'd been way
more successful with the main game that
we thought let's just go all in and make
sure the last DLC is just the best DLC
we've ever made the best DLC anyone's
ever made I'm enjoying this laser so
much it's really rad it's super
gratifying like it just melts
dudes um yeah I'm I'm glad you picked
that skill tree cuz it's it's really
gratifying to use
that cool right uh let just take this
last guy out and I think we will call it
there all right man yeah this there we
go yeah and the last DLC when we get to
announce it um you'll see too we're kind
of doing the same like nut ball like
want want to close out that season pass
like we did with the tea DLC would do
something really crazy and over the top
and really fun and big so awesome so
you've just now you're like among
probably there's there's I can probably
count on one hand the number of people
outside of the 2K and gearbox Studio
that have played as Jack and you're
amongst them now did all of them go with
a crown because I think that's no you're
the only guy that's played with the
crown in fact you're the only guy in
fact you're the only guy I showed the uh
the the heads and skins too that that
start unlock now you'll collect a lot
more heads and skins of course as you
play the game and there's really some
really funny stuff but yeah so I I broke
multiple Ru rules with you but whatever
it's coming out it's coming out on the
11th it's not like it's not like this is
like the longest drawn out you know teas
or whatever November November 11th is
nov 11th actually in Australian time no
see that's funny because when it's
November 11 in the United States it's
going to be November 12th here yeah so
it's going to launch at the same time
worldwide but your calendar will say 12
and mine will say 11 so good catch good
catch good catch what is the actual name
of the DLC pack I think we're calling it
The doppelganger pack or the Handsome
Jack doppelganger pack or just Handsome
Jack or it'll it'll be something like
that so when you see it on like
PlayStation Network or on the Xbox
Marketplace um on Steam it'll be called
something like that doppelganger
Handsome Jack Character Pack something
like that and if you have the season
pass it's included yeah so you know the
season pass will give you all four DLC
packages but it only costs the price of
three so it's pretty good deal if you
haven't gotten that yet awesome well
thank you very much for joining me glad
to be herec cheers right on uh for more
on Borderlands the Pre-Sequel and the
double gang of pack check out
gamespot.com